[Applause]
[Music]
it's Sunday in Lagos
Nigeria and it's time for
[Music]
church I've come to this delightfully
neon house of worship with a certain
degree of reluctance but when one of
Africa's Tech Titans invites you to his
church you say yes I have to warn you I
come from a long line of atheist I'm not
uh it's okay not that is exactly who we
need at
church just experience it and then
that's it you know no
[Music]
Miracles like everything here service is
high
energy enough energy to make a
non-believer
smile
nobody nobody shows faor like Jesus
nobody
[Music]
[Applause]
nobody
what I tell you or even show you next
will not do Legos
[Applause]
Justice this is a city you have to feel
if you're to have any hope understanding
it more than 26 million
people every single one of them striving
and selling
constantly for a laid-back Californian
the energy here is exhilarating and
sometimes
unnerving I've never seen anything quite
like it I am here at the largest market
in Legos as you can see it's barely
Controlled Chaos it's just block after
block after block selling everything you
can possibly
imagine it's like this just every day
yep what everybody just comes here to
get yeah all kinds of stuff anything
literally almost anything at best
prices Michael here is a local
entrepreneur and solver of problems and
my much- needed Guide to the market
we're on this street which is pretty
busy but I mean there streets in there
where there's like no cars just cars
can't even get through it's a whole
Market you literally have to squeeze
your way through you know so it's it's
pretty
intense
you can hear theying CH inow that's
white man white man white man that's
what they're saying
yeah that kissing sound is that
considered rude or that's just like
standard operating Precision it's
standard up bre proed to get someone's
attention
yeah seems like a hard way to make a
living man it is yeah it is but some
people make good money here
as you get it from the lowest prices
and you sell it for however smart you
can sell it
for locals will be quick to tell you
that Lagos is the Beating Heart of
Nigeria and that Nigeria is the Beating
Heart of
Africa and they'll also tell you that if
if Lagos can fix some things it's
infrastructure it's corruption it's old
ways of thinking
well then there's a historic economic
Revolution at the ready led by a nent
tech scene that is ready to boom and no
one wants to see this happen more than
this man who most people call E my full
name is in but most people can't
pronounce it so everybody calls me e
just the letter um I'm the founding
partner of the fun for Africa's
future Africa has seven Tech startups
valued at more than $1 billion and he
started two of them andela and
flutterwave he's often hailed as the
Zuck or musk of Nigeria although in this
case that's meant as a
compliment starting a startup here was
not easy I something about you guys
getting kicked out of offices oh man
stories for days going most people
assumed if you had a computer you were a
Yahoo boy yeah is Yahoo boy is that a
yeah that's Nigerian name or that's a
Nigerian
okay and that's why is this the scams
people always scams yeah so people who
do scams we call them Yahoo boys okay
yeah no no disrespect to Yahoo I I
should probably take that off and say
something
[Music]
else we're actually in the part of Legos
where you grew up I think right I lived
here what is this part called it's
called Yaba
how close is this to where you actually
grew up so far I I could walk my house
where I was born is maybe a 45 minute
walk from here and I went to Primary
School literally right over those rail
tracks okay could we have a little drive
around just see yeah we drive around
theuns from your childhood see
everything the population of Lagos has
exploded over the past 20 years the
result is unplanned unzoned put anything
anywhere you can
Havoc that said much of the business and
wealth is clustered on Victoria Island
which people describe as the Manhattan
of
Lagos even though he's well off now Eve
very purposefully rejected living on the
island to stick to his youthful and Tech
routes in Yaba when you say this is the
ground zero of tech to startups the
startups Talent the Talent Live this
cheapest best place to live so kind of
where all the all the startups that.com
hang out yeah
yeah the startups are here in large part
because of the local University so we
are on the campus of University of Lagos
which is one of the most amazing
universities and that's why Yaba is in
such proximity because the talent found
it easier to waft over yeah this nice
interplay between the the part of town
and the university exactly a lot of
Youth here yeah get ready to go go do
big
things but to do big things in Legos you
have to master how Legos
works and learn how to navigate its
unique flavor of business Customs when I
was at andela people didn't know how we
did it but we had 300 kids they were
walking there with 300 MacBooks each
worth
$1,000 back and forth every day in this
neighborhood people were like how how
did you do that but it was in the
neighborhood
watch neighborhood watch in this case
refers to the lagosian phenomenon of
area boys these are people who control
neighborhoods in an unofficial but very
real
capacity one word to describe the area
boys might be
Mafia it sounds bad and there's some
truth to
it many people here though don't really
trust the police to begin with
and the area boys are a more local Force
for maintaining
order the trick is to learn how to
operate within the system I gave their
leader a title was my chief security
officer gave me a badge um give him a
package including health insurance for
all his guys and we were good he made
sure everybody was safe the whole
neighborhood was safe but if you don't
know Nigeria it can be a very hard piece
to business the moment you understand
he's business savvy showed itself early
in
life as a kid he helped his mom Hawk
stock fish and ice blocks in the streets
and he discovered that he was pretty
good at it I just picked up
entrepreneurship skills very very easily
I imagine it came from ultimately being
the kind of kid who really liked money
like money I love money I love money I
remember when I was growing up I wanted
to be uh a policeman because I saw the
the only ones who were taking money from
the
drivers I didn't understand then that
were supposed to and my dad made a very
very significant decision his children
would all go to the best possible School
even if he couldn't ordinarily afford it
he went to Canada to continue his
education in the tech hotspot of waterl
Ontario he and a few friends discovered
their calling you had a little Nigerian
crew in in Canada
yeah I pull my people with
me I started to tell my Nigerian people
look there's a lot more to this school
than just getting the degree and staying
here trying to get a passport at the
time our motivations were in so Noble I
me want to just make money for
ourselves he convinced his friends to
abandon their secure career paths in
North America come back to Nigeria and
try to make it big in
Tech
in 2014 they started andela which aimed
to train up a new generation of Nigerian
coders and get them remote gigs from
around the world it was the right idea
at the right time and it became a
smashing success that allowed e to start
his payments company flutterwave another
smashing success if somebody would have
told you you would create $2 billion cup
of days Ma I never
believe well you know one thing I'll say
I did have faith that we would do
something big yeah I just didn't knew it
was going to be this big this
[Music]
soon Nigeria's Tech scene has been on a
good
run but its long-term prospects face the
same challenges as other Industries in
the
country the power infrastructure is a
terrible mess there are blackouts almost
daily and people rely on diesel
generators to get
by its roads and accompanying traffic
are just as
bad the political system is in constant
turmoil few people I talked to trusted
any political
regime in general conditions are
unstable and it's hard to get things
done everyone I talk to here is
optimistic about the future but people
always point back to the infrastructure
not really changing much or or upgrading
for decades the reality is our
infrastructure has been this way for
ages because we have lacked for a long
time the investment to make it any
better when I talked to American Capal I
think this the images of The Starving
kid with a fly on their nose is so stuck
in their heads that actually it's a lot
easier to have a conversation with them
about philanthropy that it is about
investment he knows of what he
speaks he has gone to the heart of VC
land and was rather curiously dismissed
in spite of his multi-billion dollar
track record I sort of arrived to the
Kali thinking that what I had done in
Africa would
matter but it
didn't that's kind of Twisted because if
somebody had done the same thing in the
US people would be following all over
them it is a different standard to some
extent but I think it's it's better
because we've now learned to be very
self assured and confident in what we do
here uninterested in waiting for foreign
Capital to find Nigeria and Africa e has
taken matters into his own
hands his future Africa fund has
invested in about 50 startups
here one is a company called relief
which is trying to modernize the
business of Nigerian
farming it was co-founded in 2017 by
this fella aenna
AI he's Nigerian by background but was
raised in the US everything here comes
with a negotiation like like every step
yeah how how did you get used to this or
how did you figure this all out so I
wasn't used to it at no I wasn't used to
it at first I started meditating and
actually actually did me a lot of
good you guys have you got this mix of
machines and then software and and
Technology maybe should we start with
the Kraken yeah let's start with
Kraken the Kraken is basically a really
well-made Nutcracker sadly no tentacles
are
involved the idea is to automate some of
the production of palm oil a process
that's often done by hand
here so when you're cracking open the
nuts you want to apply enough force that
you crack the shell but not that you
crack the kernel that's within the shell
it's kind of like this perfect medium
that you have to find between the
two and like True Tech try hards they
use satellites and AI to locate new
customers this really funky map that is
basically our ability to see Farms from
space um and then go and meet the
farmers so to do this some AI was just
trained up to to be able to spot the
pattern of of those triangle shaped yeah
trees everywhere the orange
touches uh is is where an oil palm uh
Farm
is what called you back to the country
and called you to do farming in
particular I think it was a mix of like
my passion for seeing economic
development in Africa and also just the
period of time that we are living in
Africa is really in the period where it
can boom and so this is actually the
point in time to create solutions that
will expand into a large piece of market
share over the next 10
[Applause]
years other startups in E portfolio are
more like your typical Silicon Valley
joint think app-based delivery services
for urban professionals though with a
particularly lagosian
twist Eden life is one example the
company was started by NAD anessi a BFF
of e he's one of the original crew of
Nigerians who met in Canada and became
the tech Kings of Lagos you became like
the Maybe I'm Wrong it seems like the
Nigerian equivalent of the PayPal Mafia
or something like that right you started
so many companies and are you guys like
are we like
celebrities no no we're not we're not
we're
not after helping build andela with e
NAD set out on his own with Eden
life the company delivers food and does
a smattering of other chores like
laundry and gardening for busy
middleclass Nigerians it's these
Services of day-to-day life to free up
more time for you to do whatever you
want to be doing is that the basic idea
yes exactly exactly everybody is like
tremendous Talent everybody is working
harder and harder every day to try to
make it but there's different roadblocks
in the way yeah for example if you're
living in a place like Lagos and you're
going to work every day you're probably
spending like 5 to 6 hours in
[Music]
traffic he's not kidding about the
traffic at
all
to get to Victoria Island and its sweet
sweet opportunities people have to cross
this bridge every
day it's 2 hours one way if you're
lucky eeden life aims to help people
claw back some of that time and
ultimately to become the go-to app for
all manner of services we describe what
we are building as the operating system
for life okay where you can find all of
these things uh in one
place nod certainly has Silicon Valley
speak down cold though personally I'm
not sure I want an operating system for
Life still Eden life represents the next
stage in Nigeria's Tech
Evolution the country has a seemingly
infinite number of Mobile payment
companies and of course crypto
everything what it needs now are new
ideas and lots of
them so like andela flutter wave I mean
had huge International investors you
know are those sort of one-offs or now
those investors have seen the success
here and that's brought in more or is it
still really hard to get International
capital for startups it's definitely
easier than it was in 2014 yeah I'll say
that by orders of magnitude right for
multiple reasons one is is the amount of
talents that's here and so we're seeing
a lot more startups get funded the
flywheel is definitely spinning
the andela mafia is a lot like the
PayPal
Mafia but with less ketamine and
fomenting of civil
unrest nonetheless it seemed like fun to
reminisce with the Nigerian coating
kingpins over spicy goat pepper
stew the two close friends met at school
in Canada then came back to Lagos in
2013 to chase their startup dreams so
how old were you when you met at like 16
or something yeah okay yeah so what' you
think yeah so my first impression of e
was why is this guy so grown up right
now who was always helping people with
their essays yeah I read a lot of ESS
like I was like yeah to be fair the
Russian kids were paying me
so when you told your parents you all
coming back to do this thing after
everybody's got
Canada everyone was okay or they tried
to talk you out of it mine was an allout
War cuz you know keep in mind I I was
already here right they're just like you
should have tried harder to find a job
what do you think you can't find a job
for me it was just I I I was ready I was
ready I was like yeah this is the
adventure of a lifetime everybody had to
sleep on the floor cuz we couldn't
afford a
bed so that was a it was real hustle
proper startup life man yeah yeah it was
really bad back then I used to drink a
lot we used to do something called
Breakfast of Champions a vodka shot and
a Red
Bull I've had this breakfast of
sh was it scary or was it like you said
it was just exciting and you just had to
see it through well to be fair this man
right here is a very sacrificial man and
and uh he put in a lot to to make the
transition smooth I try I try to keep
all the scary parts away from it's
fine the Shand for what these men are
talking about is Passion did you go to
this facility yeah it's what drove them
to build their companies and it's what's
driving them now to try and set Nigeria
on a new
course and the good news is that if
Nigeria has anything in it ample
quantity it's
[Applause]
[Music]
passion good evening ladies and
gentlemen welcome to goab open mik night
any kind of talent please let me know
and we will get your name on the list
it's Thursday night in Legos I'm at the
BOGO beer house all week people have
been telling me come here see some
spoken words some music all kinds of
stuff so I'm going to go in please make
some noise for senior boy in the
[Applause]
[Music]
buildy as with any open mic night
there's a range of
quality but the best AXS are face
meltingly
[Music]
great that greatness has made Nigerian
music a global
phenomenon offering proof of the massive
stage on which Nigeria can
[Music]
play
thank you so
much but to really talk about Nigeria as
a cultural Force we have to talk about
one extraordinary
man the carismatic controversial and
legendary musician
fouti who kicked off the afro beat
movement in the
1960s fell merged Nigerian sound with
jazz soul and the blues he sang about
love and life and also about the plight
of his people fellow right at the
government and what he saw as its
corruption and neglect he was an artist
and a revolutionary all rolled up into
one people still come to pay tribute at
this club that acts as a kind of shrine
to fella
here you can bask in the aura of the
great man and peruse various
memorabilia I would comment on this
exhibit but this is a family
[Applause]
show Hi man Clinton is my name I'm on
the
microphone let him know we don't play
right now let's go butoi started with
afro beat has since morphed into afro
Beats aor glorious profusion of West
African pop
Styles these are the sounds of the
country heard on every street corner in
every club and in every home and this
music has washed over the entire
world turning Nigerian artists like bnab
boy and whiz kid into Global
[Music]
[Applause]
icons one of the Heavy Hitters of the
scene is beny Wellington a singer and
rapper turned entertainment
Mogul so it started as me as an artist
to me starting a record label and
discovering other artists and producers
and DJs and music business Executives um
all kind of got their start with us and
then over the years we've morphed into
movies uh I'm a filmmaker I've
co-executive produced some some films
that have done pretty well
yeah
you and your wife seem like the
celebrity couple of Nigeria for what I
could gather man I'll let you see
that beny believes in Nigeria which is
why he came back to live here after
going to University in New York he's
even run for political office hoping to
create more opportunities for young
people but not everyone who leaves
Nigeria is quite so eager to return I
remember when I told my folks that I
wanted to move back to Nigeria cuz my
parents don't live here anymore I mean
they haven't lived here for a few
decades I remember my folks said you
want to sing sing in New York City that
people are singing there like what are
you going back to Nigeria to
do a lot of noise has been made about
The Jacka syndrome people what is that
oh Jacka is when uh people leave they go
for for other opportunities outside of
the country and and you know we've seen
quite a few of our bright Minds do
that Nigeria suffers from a deep brain
drain holding back the country's techine
from reaching its full
potential increasingly though Nigerians
who have made it overseas are returning
with their skills and their money
sometimes permanently sometimes in more
of a hybrid
fashion one of these people is KL
a dealmaker with Capricorn Investment
Group Klay grew up in Nigeria and has
made Africa his Focus as an investor so
did you guys grow up pretty middle class
upper class you know I think from the
perspective that I look at it I would
say middle class um but I think my
parents made a lot of sacrifices for us
and I only know this looking back I
studied chemical engineering and had the
opportunity to go to the US to do
that did you have ever think you'd be
coming back to Africa to BU startups and
no but I have about 30 plus companies
that I've invested in now uh not just in
Nigeria but across the
[Music]
continent Klay brought me 3 hours north
of Lagos to iidon the capital of Oyo
State this is cool man it's kind of so
different than Legos seems like what one
notch down frenetic yeah yeah definitely
one notch
down we had two missions to meet one of
klay's friends a local politician and to
visit kl's
grandmother first though we'd have to
get
[Music]
gas that's not a scene we'd usually put
in the
show then
again
it usually doesn't look like
this to understand what's going on here
takes a bit of
explaining shortly after I arrived in
Nigeria a new president Bola Ahmed tonu
took
office his first major Act was to end
the government subsidies for
gasoline this triggered an immediate
Panic through throughout the
country people rushed to gas stations to
try and beat price
hikes the gas stations were then
barricaded in a bid to control the
situation and simply filling up your car
became an
ordeal the underlying problem here is
that Nigeria has lots of oil but no
refineries to process
it oil is exported refined and then
brought back with Nigeria usually
getting the drgs of the production
Africa's richest person Alo dangote just
paid close to $20 billion to build the
First new modern refinery in the
country you're building one of the
largest refineries in the world yes is
650,000 B
City so there's hope that with the right
Investments things can
improve but such examples are few and
far
between these economic woses make it
even harder for Tech to flourish
here and almost no one seems to believe
that the government can make things
better except apparently for this man
bio aund I don't know if you're aware of
this but some people are cynical about
the government here you know how much
progress what do you mean we're not
aware about that like what are you
talking
about actually I was one of those people
four years ago and I think um we can be
on the outside and complain forever or
we can actually try to come in and make
a
[Music]
change bio is a former entrepreneur who
decided to go into
politics his mission has been to
modernize the government of oo State and
lay the groundwork for tech companies to
set up shop here we're very interested
in um internet penetration so we've laid
um fiber cables fiber docks almost a
thousand over the past few years we're
planning to do a couple thousand more
yeah they always say the second
highspeed internet lights up in a
country is education improves job
prospects improve all of
that bio is also putting technology to
work fighting graft which many Nigerians
say runs rampant throughout the
government here we we were talking too
about the if $12 billion goes to the
construction of a new Road only 2
billion actually make it to the road
after sort of money's changed hands so
what we've done here for example one of
the first things we did was every single
contract procurement should be put
online the whole process is transparent
and the money is to be dispersed also
online so full information transparency
across the entire
process all this bio hopes can make life
a little better and easier for everyday
Nigerians and help convince young Tech
entrepreneurs that they should build
their Futures
[Music]
here if you can just make life a little
better for them nobody wants to leave
home yeah you know if they can they
would stay here and Thrive here maybe
earn from there but live here so it's
policies man so I mean I trust bio he
seems nice and well-intentioned
[Music]
but for the real talk on the real
Nigeria I knew where we had to go next
welcome toon this is my grandma's home
thank you lots of fun memories here so
let's go say hi to to
Grandma hello
Grandma oh good to see
Grandma this is Ashley hello hi Ashley
grandma thank
you Mrs Grace SoMo a Pampa was born in
Nigeria went to college in England and
came back in 1959 just a year before
independence is that
you no that's she worked at the
University of Nigeria's teaching
Hospital while raising several kids and
she remains a mom at
heart the gentleman let them eat it now
you only give them one one and um
Grandma they they're busy that's why
they're busy with the cameras tell them
to help themselves then okay yes please
help
yourselves my grandchildren are all over
they scattered all over are all over the
world happy that they all over the world
okay but I miss them
[Music]
yeah Madam Grace has witnessed
generations of change here but still
keeps us Shar eye on current events I
just learned about the refinery on this
visit I mean the country should be
refining its own oil yeah we send the
crude oil we sell it to foreigners yeah
they return it to us at a exorbitant
it's crazy it's crazy yeah how do you
feel about the young the youth the
youngsters and and do they give you hope
for where the country is heading I I
think the future is bright for them but
we have to come together they have to
come home do this thing together
together yeah not running away we have
to be together stay and do it she's
talking to you yeah she is talking to
me I accept the
[Laughter]
challenge back in Legos you can find a
number of startups that Klay has backed
with an eye toward making real change
for everyday
[Music]
Nigerians Tech investers have claimed
such Noble intentions since at least the
Stone Age hello my friends welcome to VI
your
class but here in Nigeria there's a case
to be made the tech might actually make
things better b w x y and
Zed take tsas they make an education app
and lowcost tablet for kids and also run
in-person Learning Centers like this
one with the goal of making quality
education available for even the poorest
[Music]
households it was started by osai a
Nigerian and former Exxon executive
today is May 27th and at apparently is
children's day and is this like a Africa
wide holiday or this is a Nigerian and
so it's mainly Nigeria okay um we create
a special day for the children um where
we just celebrate them give them a good
time okay now we're going to stretch
ourselves the way osai sees it the
education in Nigerian Public Schools is
barely adequate tsas aims to fill in the
gaps and get kids ready for college and
life all for just a few dollars a month
we're focused on the whole child not
just academics right yes we prepare them
for exams but we also want them to start
developing core values that would help
them um throughout their entire lives
like being proactive right social
emotional learning can you say that
social in here they have access to the
best and the brightest tutors um and
learning coaches across the country
happy
J
[Applause]
another could layback company trying to
make things better in Nigeria is Farms
to
you it's run by Aisha raheim who spent a
few years working in finance in London
before returning to her Homeland I do go
back and forth because I also
naturalized in in England so they're
both my homes um and uh the two cities
have lived longterm Lagos London yeah
two mad houses but um lots of
entrepreneurial Spirits so I love those
cities like tsas Farms to you is not
super flashy but it is incredibly useful
the company makes software for Farmers
helping them figure out what types of
crops buyers want when the best time is
to sell a harvest and even how to get
loans you've probably got people who
have their family's been farming for
many many many years and then you're
kind of coming in you know with some new
ideas and then also you have to get the
technology in their hands in terms of
even convincing them and getting them to
think about things in a more technology
oriented way it's actually something
they're more open to because of the
impact of climate
[Music]
change the rains are coming later they
coming in heavier so for instance last
year in Nigeria we experienced one of
the heaviest floods that we've seen in
the last decade and this is why they're
more receptive and really trying to
understand how can I do things better
because they're playing with very thin
margins needless to say Nigerian farming
Logistics is not the easiest business to
be
in but for Aisha the challenges are kind
of the
point you see a port hole on the road
that's an
opportunity there isn't constant L that
is an
opportunity there is corruption as the
um you know traditional sense that's
opportunity what is actually corruption
it's just that systems are not in place
to capture certain activities because
what might be called corruption in
Nigeria might be called lobbying in us
what might be called a bribe in Nigeria
might be called a service fee in the UK
what is in Nigeria is a systems problem
it's not a people problem it's systems
and processes that needs to be in
place
by now I was feeling so inspired by the
possibilities of Nigerian Tech I felt
like I wanted to get involved
personally so I got myself an
entry-level job at a startup delivering
food to customers all over
Lagos little did I know how intense this
job would get later on over here we have
the Spaghettini we have spaghetti here
and oil
my new employer is a company called
grity which aims to sell staple foods at
the lowest possible cost they work
directly with suppliers like Aisha's
company Farms to you to buy food in bulk
and pass on the savings to low income
lagosians when I
came so this is the app okay my tenure
at grity started out well enough we're
doing the gold order all
right
you pack the food at a warehouse all
right I'll follow you you pop it in a
delivery
vehicle teamw work Makes the Dream
workor
yeah then you drive through the crazy
streets of Lagos to reach your hungry
customer Lagos is a kind of a very busy
Place sometimes is
stressful traffic so many
things you listen to podcast what are
you finally you arrive at the
customer where because you have a film
crew with you all hell breaks
loose we'd already had a few encounters
with the so-called area
boys Lego's neighborhood
enforcers but these guys were
particularly aggressive with their
threats of
[Music]
violence all right our arrival wasn't
that
appreciated little money was exchanged I
think and now uh now we're going to go
deliver the
groceries well I'm sorry we made your
day more
hectic all right man it was nice meeting
you enjoy the
groceries sadly that was the end of my
career as a Nigerian every
[Music]
man to ease the pain of my failure Klay
and his friend Michael took me for a
relaxing boat ride destination elasha
Beach a resort area just outside the
city where Chill Vibes can be found at
[Music]
last people from Legos come out here
just to relax or from all
to escape the chaos of the actual CTV
yeah tell me how you guys met goes as
far back as with primary school days I
reckon before he moved to the states um
and I've been here just keeping things
going I guess but you know everybody
he's got all the connections cuz he's St
if there's anyone that's plugged
in Michael has made the most of his
decision to
stay he now runs a business as a kind of
high-end fixer and guide to all things
Legos shout outs to the afro beats
artist they're making Africa Nigeria
Legos so popular everyone is trying to
come back here how much do you get when
you come back people trying to recruit
you to to come home and I I I think it's
a a mutual understanding that you know
maybe we playfully use it but people
understand the wise right I think
whether you stay here or you live abroad
our goal is just to make Lagos Nigeria a
better home for all of us
Community Food health education I think
if those basic infrastructures existed
you see less people wanting to move
they'll still struggle but they'll know
that like the basic needs are there and
they would much rather want to stay here
than go live somewhere else home at the
end of the day yeah yeah it
is Klay and Michael continued telling me
about their many prospective business
ventures and their hopes and dreams for
their country good to see man thank
you seeing Nigeria through their eyes
it's easy to imagine a bright
future the truth at least for me is that
there's something intoxicating about
this
country its problems are so obvious most
of the country's people are
struggling there's dysfunction
everywhere so many of Nigeria's best and
brightest people have fled for brighter
prospects
elsewhere but in the end there's that
energy the people who have stayed feel
it and thrive on
it anyone visiting will feel it too it's
a kind of vibrating hum that should be
and could be the backdrop for great
things
[Music]
don't